we thought we'd seen you play everything
but first witch
mostly [__] my first witch
but i hear you went through a phase of
you got offered a lot of witches
when i was 40 when i turned 40 i was
offered
three which is in one year
and it was sending me a signal i felt
about hollywood and how they felt about
people turning 40.
so i felt uh bad and i and it made me
sort of
i had like a little my backup you know
and so
no i didn't want to play them so a lot's
changed in the last five years for you
[Music]
[Applause]
that was so smooth
why haven't we seen more of you two
together
it's a pairing it really is it's a match
made in heaven
now um jackie chan yes jackie chan uh
yeah what i haven't done that once i'm
very similar
i am sitting on my hands i'm going
chucky chan i'm not doing that
because is it true that everyone just
goes jackie chan yeah
i really hate that you know
whenever i go in europe in america
especially the father with children
look yeah
why why nobody say robert de niro
that's robert de niro wow duxtin hoffman
[Laughter]
one day one day i hope people wow that's
a jackie chan
yes that's jackie chan
that i did have a sir encounter
only a few weeks ago in los angeles a
rather
fancy in fact extremely fancy restaurant
tell them what it is they'll know um it
was the uh
the the the tower bar uh
no yeah no yeah guys that's cool
no no no no no no no no se sit again
look at this
oh man
[Applause]
oh
keep going you keep going keep going
okay no the towel bar is the spot
i got a feeling this isn't gonna work
out
um so we had four of us were seated at
the table
about 15 minutes later into the
restaurant walks
sir paul mccartney wow good now
paul and i have a very slender
relationship but it's lasted decades
okay i first encountered him in 1964.
no when his girlfriend
jane asher then told him that i
loved aston martin's i was driving a
battered old ford but aston martins were
my dream car
she told him this and one night yeah we
knew he was seeing the show there was a
knock on my door
and i said yeah come in i'm there in my
underwear like
as usual
and the door opened and standing there
was paul mccartney who i had never met
before and this was 1964.
and uh he said jane says that you like
aston martin's here
drive this wow and he tossed a bunch of
keys
pretty cool and it was an ass it was
amazing
anyway do you want to hear the rest
let's keep going keep going we're in
we're in the fanciest restaurant in l.a
we're now in the tower
i am feeling less less good
keep going keep going you're in there so
paul mccartney has come in
you've known him and uh
he sees me and comes over and uh i stand
up and say hi and we have a big hug
in the restaurant and i'm very much
aware that there's
all the tables are full on this kind of
thing and we talk for five or six
minutes
and he goes and sits down five minutes
go by and
into the restaurant walks a ringo star
i swear to you i'm just saying i'm not
making this one were they together
they were they were oh they were at the
same table they were the same
[Applause]
i am expecting so many free meals
and um we finish early
and i get up to go and paul stands up to
say goodbye and we have a hug
and as we have a hug he says into my ear
do you know ringo i said yeah
of course i've never met him he said
ringo come on come over here
hang on a minute he said sir ringo
sir patrick sir paul hey
we've got the knights of the roundtable
[Applause]
well here's the thing thanks to the
world wide web anyone can now review
a hotel right and uh so we've come
across these are actual
online reviews of actual experiences
people have in hotels
so his first one i got to the hotel to
check in
and on my way to the elevator i slid
right into a pile of diarrhea
that was located near the elevator it
got on my knees and my arm as well as my
luggage
the hotel staff did not help me in any
shape or form and told me to watch where
i was going
and it was my fault how is it my fault
there is poop on the floor in the first
place
my room was horrible it smelled like
poop as well i was disgusted never again
now what i like about this is one
of two people found that review helpful
the other person no that's not helpful
he still gave it
one star yeah i know i think having
looked at these i think one's the
minimum you can't do a no-star
what's up next uh please take notice at
this view me and my husband and two kids
went to these apartments for a week and
i must say never again
we arrived at 5am and were introduced by
member of staff ismet i said you've got
passports we sat down and my daughter
13 saw two people on the sofa next to
the bar
making love whilst being videoed by the
chef
why is it closed they weren't doing a
good job
what they call making love yeah
but i like i like that service still got
two stars
the location was excellent
uh next up do not stay in this absolute
dump hotel i use the term hotel very
loosely
i cannot convey strongly enough how
disgusting this place is bloodstained
headboards
have clearly been up since world war the
first one
windows that weren't closed no hot water
broken furniture dirty utensils broken
light fittings
and actual poo in the kettle
now that's a holiday
i am so on holiday
very good let's see the next one i wish
we hadn't gone
oh now this is a weird one i don't know
whether it's an actual spelling mistake
or whether it's also correct but it
makes the review very confusing indeed
i wish we hadn't gone the meal was
ruined by midgets everywhere
and we were sitting inside
we even moved tables nearer the back
wall but we were either followed by them
or well they were at that table too we
woke up following one and covered in
bites and very itchy
that's the hotel in disneyland
all over the place get off uh do we have
another one
this is this is oh this is well anyway
we were given the keys to the wrong room
and walked into the room to find a naked
african gentleman washing his genitals
in the sink
are you whispering all of the extra
things he did
[Applause]
oh my gosh when daffodil writes a book
this is in it
and then i said to him washing his
genitals
talking about doing shocking things uh
of course
you did julie in in your husband's movie
sob yeah
you went twice what
husband we've all been around the block
jonah
this is blake edwards yes well what a
legend you guys were married to each
other are you kidding
oh my gosh will you google the other
guests
i mean i knew that she's such a legend
and he's such a legend what a legendary
combination
to that lovely guy for 42 years wow
so it's a legendary couple of my dad
yeah i'd be the only person i'd be fine
with being married to
definitely wrote a book on him sammy
watson you know that yes he wrote a book
oh god can you guys go away for a minute
like uh phil yeah that's crazy yeah oh
yeah i think maybe most of the audience
know he did all the
great pink panther movies he did um
breakfast at tiffany's and
those kind of movies but no i i had to
go uh topless
but it was very legitimate and i had
it took ten years super legitimate
it was legitimately in the script is
what i'm saying
no yes very legitimately
beautiful movie beautiful you haven't
seen it ten times but how are you happy
it's too long you love it it's all about
it's a
real takeoff on hollywood it's a very
funny sob
yes orbeez yeah oh and you've not seen
it either no i'm sorry
god well we'll play it on our wedding
night
[Music]
other people in hollywood just telling
you don't do this you're julia
no no no i mean i'd done an awful lot by
then and i had as i say it took 10 years
to get the movie made
so i had 10 years to think about it and
it was in the script and quite
as i say legitimate and it just
can be cold in the studio didn't you
find that
and it's a lot worse when it's cold for
us then
[Music]
[Applause]
chills help ladies no i don't think so
well i mean goosebumps don't look
particularly good on camera
i guess not but it's
and anthony and gregory did a boxing
challenge
and in a bit of a shock result anthony
won
[Laughter]
so this time this time we've got another
challenge with the last time it was
you know those boxing things and you hit
the box in there so that's what we did
the last time
this time we've gone for one of those
fun fair
uh test of strength machines okay okay
so if you'd like to bring in uh the
machine
here it is
[Music]
come down now to our our test of
strength now the two of you are gonna
start one you're gonna have a bit of a
face-off in front of it okay
okay we're taking this seriously no no
yeah we're taking it seriously
and it's not it's it is of strength but
i believe technique plays a huge part in
it that's what i
so oh look oh
ken brown is going to give us uh just a
little bit of form before we
do this okay you do your face off do
your face off come on come on okay off
you go
okay ladies and gentlemen on the left
they call him the postman
because he always delivers it's the
undisputed heavyweight champion of the
world
anthony joshua
on
[Laughter]
because he sometimes delivers
unless he gets stuck in traffic
it is greg man mountain david
so here we go here we go so aj
yeah you go first uh well that's almost
heavy i thought that was gonna be
heavier
okay
okay okay you go first mind the cameras
here we go
it's not golf
oh dear
[Applause]
well you might miss it as well
go hit the bell hit the bell hit the
bell come on
[Music]